alright guys bangbang I have the one and
only Dan held here let's do this man
thanks for doing it
hey thanks for having me home hub for
sure for those that don't know you
who the hell is Dan held is your
background yeah so I got into the crypto
space for around 2012 and early 2013 I
moved out to San Francisco
it's got involved with Bitcoin meetup
space back in that day there's only like
a dozen people that went to the Bitcoin
meetups in San Francisco which was like
Brian and Fred from coinbase Charlie
liège and McCaleb you had Jared Kenna
from Tradehill
and you know got involved in this
community really you know I understood
Bitcoin back in 12 sort of to play
around with it
13 kind of went full you know dived
dived in really deep as to how it worked
understanding a little bit more about it
and then in the March 2013 bubble a lot
of people forget that there was two
bubbles in 2013 the March 2013 pebble
won the when this price spiked I saw
that happen and realized that there was
no mobile app that provide real-time
market that provided a real-time market
data so I co-founded that with a buddy
and that became one of the most popular
crypto apps in 2013 we got acquired by
blockchain calm I came on board there as
director of product worked there for
about a year then went to change dip
change dicted micro payments over social
media so those tipping box that you see
on Reddit and Twitter after that one to
Eber were worked on right or growth and
the intelligence team left uber went to
interchange a start-up that'd post trade
reconciliation for crypto hedge funds we
got acquired by Kraken and now I'm
director of business development over
Kraken all right let's go back to 2012
you're sitting in these meetups in San
Francisco what did what are people
talking about that are they like hey
this gonna be the next global reserve
currency or are they saying wow we're
weird as [ __ ] and I hope this thing
actually works it was more weird you
know it's a we think we had a cooler of
PBRs Tradehill at the time was
sponsoring the Meetup and I think
Tradehill had raised like a few million
dollars that was like the big
Browns in crypto at the time so and I
think coinbase is like four million
dollar seed a little bit later was like
the next biggest deal in crypto for that
time so yeah as a cooler of PBR is a
bunch of kind of we felt like we were
weirdos hanging out and talking about
how Bitcoin mine might be the next world
reserve currency but it's a little hard
to put say that with a straight face
when there was only a dozen of you in
the room for sure and I guess like
obviously many of the people you just
described that rat that meet up have
gone on to to be kind of luminaries in
encrypted in general and Bitcoin and
also built a number of pretty large
companies what do you think was kind of
like in the water there was it just hey
these people had a vision and they saw
it early and naturally they were kind of
pre-selected you know to end up being
that people who bought those companies
or what do you think was kind of the
commonality yeah that's a great question
so I think that early cohort of Bitcoin
adopters a lot of the products and
services that we see here today like
wallets trading infrastructure hadn't
really been developed so these
individuals loved Bitcoin so much that
they wanted to go build that
infrastructure you know Tradehill
the first u.s. exchange was co-founded
in 2011 and that was based on like
different pain points that people had
with Cox and you look at these different
things that were built in a lot of it or
like Satoshi you're sorry Satoshi lights
being you know Trevor Lee he you know
created litecoin a lot of these people
were tinkerers or builders they wanted
to go build that infrastructure they
wanted to tinker with Bitcoin it was a
very kind of roll up your sleeves and
try out something new sort of sort of
vibe going on and so obviously you have
been through multiple boom and bust
cycles at this point kind of talk
through just like the very first one
where you saw Bitcoin you know exploded
value and then turn around and crash
over a period of time like what was the
general emotions where people like hey
it's over kind of just talk through a
little bit about that very first one
that you you experienced yeah so I
actually started to dig through some of
my old emails
to look for the first time I mentioned
the word Bitcoin and actually found that
it been through four cycles I thought I
had just been through three early 13
late 13 and 17 but in 2012 I found an
email and the first time I say the word
Bitcoin I say bitcoins I'm so I'm so
embarrassed it's you know back in that
day so when the the language in nuance
was still being developed for me so you
know I think when I first looked at it
it seemed like this kind of weird
digital internet money right it's not
backed by anything there's no reserve
there's no central bank sort of propping
it up so it seemed like the Wild West I
think 13 was the one I remember the most
though because I was out here in San
Francisco
I was plugged into the space you know
you could feel the energy and vibe when
you went into the Meetup
now while there was only a dozen people
at the beginning of the year by the time
March came around when the price spike
to 260 from $10 there was over a hundred
you know I'd like Lightspeed Venture
Partners slinging out business cards and
you know I think it was it was a pretty
wild experience to see you know an
investment 26x
I mean that doesn't that doesn't really
happen so that was pretty wild and then
to see the wave of new adopters and see
all the people interested was a
validation that I wasn't crazy I mean
back in 2012 and he believed in Bitcoin
you felt a little nuts like you believed
in this weird Internet money that was
super weird I mean it had barely been
covered by mainstream press you know
remember this is pre coin desk days
wasn't even coin desk around so the main
areas the main places that I learned
about Bitcoin were Bitcoin talk or the
are Bitcoin subreddit and so I think
that kind of earlier vibe was it was
pretty wild to see like it become start
to become mainstream a little spark that
this might be something bigger than just
a group of nerds in a small room in San
Francisco yeah and obviously the
happenings you know are kind of top of
mine right now given that we've got one
about ten days away or so
but let's go back to kind of the first
one that you really went through as part
of the community like what was the
conversation at that point kind of how
are people thinking about it was it well
understood did it catch people by
surprise just kind of you know help us
understand like what the general vibe
was around that first happening 2016 was
the first one I'd like to really
remember and paid attention to and I
went to the bid go having party down and
I think they were down in Colorado at
the time it was pretty boring to be
honest I mean the content in the space
was basically non-existent
even though coin desk you know different
crypto publications existed and there
were great thought leaders like Jameson
lob had a good blog at the time wasn't
nearly the plethora of podcast YouTube
channels great content writers you know
I think that it was still very kind of
geeky back then and 2016 was pretty
freaking bearish I think I mean I think
it was at late 15 or 16 where Bitcoin
hit a hundred and eighty dollars that
was uh that was pretty demoralizing so
it was a very low-energy sort of moment
back in 2016 a lot of us were huddling
and just kind of waiting for kind of a
brighter future so I I'd say that's very
much in stark contrast to where we are
now where there's a lot of enthusiasm
you know Krakens hosting a VR having
event
Krakens had you know has hundreds of
employees and back then and had dozens
so just a huge big distinct difference
in terms of size the community and
enthusiasm and in support you know that
content helps us all reinforce that
narrative with each other that we're in
you know we're into Bitcoin for XYZ
reason and without that narrative
support it feels very lonely but I feel
very very much connected and and you
know I think that's an incredible
feeling four hot alarms to have going
into the next twenty twenty having for
sure and I guess like was there an
understanding of like it's actually
going to happen this is how it works
here's what the impact should be in kind
of what I consider more of the
kind of second and third order effects
of the having or was it just hey there's
this event that's occurring and I'm
literally going to a party
and people were just kind of looking at
the price and didn't kind of think about
I think what a lot now as more kind of
financially the people that have come in
the interesting of the supply shocks and
things like that yeah I mean it was very
much like this is an event but it wasn't
like oh this is going to guarantee a you
know speculative bubble to occur after
this I think a lot of people had
theorized it we got to remember that
2012 the space was so tiny that not a
lot of people felt that that was a valid
data point so 2016 really validated that
the reduction in supply could
potentially increase the sensitivity of
demand as you know sort of the total
supply like we've got you know the flow
of newly minted coins in the block
subsidy would have been inside the block
reward as that happens through the
happening the amount of newly minted
coins hitting the circulating supply
decreases so a lot of people look at the
total amount of bitcoins produced and
the newly minted coins relative to that
I think the more appropriate measures to
look at the newly minted coins relative
to the circulating supply as in like the
you know we look at UT X OS and we can
look at a lot of coins haven't moved
four or five six years to three years I
mean I'm talking about active supply so
you know I think that no one there
wasn't stock to flow models back then
there wasn't a lot of like intellectual
rigor
I mean turd of Easter was basically the
only Bitcoin economist a lot of people
you know we've got so many great thought
leaders like thought leaders in space to
help but Tura was like I remember I
remember seeing her I remember emailing
Turing 2015-2016 and asking them because
he had just put together why bitcoin is
a good gold like investment and I wanted
to give that to my father so turn have
like the only I would consider in-depth
research at that time and they're just
having been a lot of the lid you know
the the that having inducing a
speculative bubble really hadn't been
validated past that first twenty twelve
I've been so I would say we've got so
much more intellectual and technical
rigor as to like why we hypothesized a
supply cut me
make demand a little bit more sensitive
but you know that really didn't exist
back in that day for sure and I guess is
that the biggest difference you see
between then and now is just like that
more kind of rigor and scrutiny and
analysis or the other things that you
kind of can pinpoint and say hey look
this is a big difference today going
into the third having then than the
second one yeah I think a lot of people
look at like the tweets that I put out
and I'm very bullish on Bitcoin
obviously and kind of short and quippy
and a lot of people go oh you're just
like a perma bowl of perma Bowl like you
never really you know really being
intellectually honest about you know
your the the risks of concerns about
that coin and I'm like dude coming from
back then like we have a thousand decks
deeper liquidity we have we don't just
have mal Cox like we didn't know if
bitcoin was gonna come back after mal
Cox Clapton collapsed you know we've got
dozens of venues you know crack and
being like a super-strong one we've got
dozens of venues we have all these
institutional pipes plugged in and I
know you've talked a lot about that all
this stuff we've gotten tens of millions
of ha dollars we've got great content to
reinforce that shared belief and faith
in Bitcoin Bitcoin survived a global
pandemic where we saw markets just have
a huge sell-off and a series of
cascading margin calls no Bitcoin
survived that and now we basically
retraced from that bottom that's
incredible I mean Bitcoin has no
university that endorses it no
government that endorses it and no no
investment makes em endorse it so the
fact that the aggregate shared belief of
HA dollars kept Bitcoin from going to
zero and in a moment of like pure fear
this isn't just financial fear this is
like fear for your life that's
incredible I think Bitcoin has
demonstrated its resiliency far beyond
what I thought I was capable of doing in
its short lifespan so I think that the
compare and contrast here from back in
the day compared to now is that the
Bitcoin is demonstrated its resiliency
and has become so large that you know my
original investment thesis when I
in 2012 was that it was a goal 2.0 it
has largely demonstrated that over the
last eight years I've been in this pace
yeah
the most important question around the
having is is it having or happening
which one you always I used to say
havening but I think having is more
popular and so I'm trying to wean myself
off of happening so it's it's a slow
process so if you'd noticed I think I've
said boast during the during the chat I
I keep joking people I don't think that
neither one is right or wrong I think
that it's a split decision big I hear
people saying both of them I guess
having a shorter and sweeter and I saw
some Twitter polls where people liked
that one a little bit more but you have
any as my old go to and so it's a little
hard to wean off that for sure now one
of the things that is kind of a
double-edged sword if you will is the
financialization of Bitcoin right so
back in 2012 up till it's called
2017-2018 it was pretty much if you were
into Bitcoin it would I don't say
anti-wall Street but definitely had a
different vibe different ethos a
different community than a lot of what
you see in Wall Street and traditional
financial legacy finance there's been a
blurring of that line over the last few
years some of that is seen as a positive
development right getting more liquidity
into the market kind of more
sophisticated players a lot of the more
significant analysis you get kind of in
the mainstream press more all that kind
of stuff
there's also concern though around the
financialization of Bitcoin leading to a
dampened upside potential because it
kind of gets incorporated into some of
those more legacy markets and asset
classes and funds how do you think about
this right like what are the positives
and negatives and kind of where do you
think that we come out on a net basis
it's a great question I think there's a
lot of anxiety in this space around what
happens when the institutions do come
you know in late 17 we hypothesize that
they would come a little bit earlier and
I do think they will come and I think I
see it as some sort of an inevitable
thing that will occur it's nothing to be
afraid of I think a lot of people look
at this and there's this anxiety around
okay what happen
wallstreet comes it's big evil Wall
Street coming in get a mess with Bitcoin
my little cypherpunk
you know dream and I don't think it's a
bad thing so you know first and foremost
different financial instruments like
futures options and lending and
borrowing are all normal market
activities they enhance price discovery
the enhance liquidity and they allow
different operators in the crypto space
or in Bitcoin specifically to hedge
their risk so this means that you know
potentially options have the ability to
dampen you know the the downside risk
for miners which is a good thing so
maybe we have a more continuous hash
rate rather than difficulty adjustments
that are lower difficulty adjustments so
you know I don't think it's a bad or
good thing I think it's a basically a
market neutral thing it's how markets
work they essentially allow the
efficient price discovery the yellow
market participants to hedge if certain
types of risk all of the different
financial instruments that I've seen
come out I think are great for different
operators like I said before I think a
big one that a lot of people have a
sticking point with is lending and
borrowing because people go oh
fractional reserve lending is bad and I
say well how much is bad
so yes fractional reserve banking has
led to what we've seen you know Bank
different Bank issues over many many
times over the last four hundred five
hundred years in terms of all fighting
you know financial recorded data we do
see that after a decade or two we
typically have like bank runs people go
to their bank the bank has done
fractional reserve banking and their
money may or may not be there fractional
reserve banking in and of itself is not
a bad thing the bank compensates you for
that risk by offering you an interest
rate you should be evaluating the
different risks at the banks in which
you deposit your coins at or at a policy
of money you should be evaluating the
risks in which you were being
compensated for with that interest rate
Thanks sort of a good function in the
economy which is to lend money to
individuals who don't have that money
now whether that be your personal home
personal car or
business these aren't bad things loans
in bond lending and borrowing is not a
bad function when we do too much of it
it becomes a bad thing and so I think
Bitcoin at that basely or having only 21
million bitcoins that immutable monetary
policy where it cannot be changed the
settlement and the custodial guarantee
that you have when you hold Bitcoin
yourself that's phenomenal I think that
alone is a huge breakthrough in the
world economy and so yes if you choose
to take on a more risk and give your
coins to different lending companies out
there you're being compensated for that
risk now is 3 5 6 percent enough I don't
know that's a subjective thing but I
don't think it's an inherently bad thing
yeah and I guess it kind of leads into
another aspect of the financialization
is you get more sophisticated players
that come into the market they have that
experience from various asset classes
and there's a lot of people who say look
these markets are incredibly manipulated
right there's whales out there these
people know what they're doing and
they're able to increase and decrease
price through manipulation how do you
think about that and do you think it's a
fair kind of accusation to say that
those are the sophisticated non Bitcoin
type audience doing that or do you think
it's maybe kind of everyone in the
market yes so the concern over Wales
because we're all minnows and dolphins
as some people put it you know we're
worried about these whales splashing
around and causing us to you know
causing these really intense price
gyrations whales have been a concern
since 2012 I remember a lot of the
Bitcoin talk there I think there's a
wall observer is one of the oldest
threads on Bitcoin talk where people
talk about giant bitter haskell walls
where a whale will go put a giant wall
in to kind of scare the market the most
famous one is called the bear whale so
from 2015 I think an individual put in a
30 million dollar cell wall that was
eaten by bitcoiners
and it's a famous date where we slayed
the bear whales so if you google the
slaying of the bear whale that's when
the bitcoiners all came together to slay
that there will as Bitcoin has increased
in adoption in terms of number of
hollers liquidity and liquidity I mean
what I mean by that is the bid-ask
spread the depth of the order book in
volume as is of all increased so you
have more market participants and
greater liquidity the ability for a
whale to influence the market is
diminished because there are more market
participants that they have to fight
against which would be I guess what you
could call maybe like a true price a
price minus the influence of one single
participant every market has large
participants you have tech companies
where founders hold twenty thirty forty
percent of the company you have
different types of commodities where a
certain investment bank or hedge fund
might own a larger percentage we cannot
control who owns X percentage of Bitcoin
as the markets become more liquid those
large ha blurs of Bitcoin will be able
to influence the price less and less got
it and so obviously one of the big
questions is when you've got somebody
who's who's incredibly bullish I get
this all the time there's a bunch of
people asking what percent of your
assets you have in Bitcoin and then what
other assets do you have and how do you
think about kind of portfolio
construction in general yeah so I take
an incredibly risky and I would not
advise this sort of what sort of
portfolio construction but I am over
ninety percent of my net worth is in
Bitcoin now this isn't something to
where you know I bought a lot of Bitcoin
back in the day I sold zero block for
Bitcoin to blocking comm a lot of people
go oh wow that was that's really cool
you know that's really cool you sold
your company for Bitcoin and I'm like
well I sold my company for Bitcoin when
Bitcoin is worth $1200 at the peak of
2013 it didn't feel so good when Bitcoin
was a hundred and eighty dollars at the
bottom of the bear now you really have
to believe in Bitcoin to make it through
these cycles right the volatility is so
intense that I think after this asset
class if I ever were to invest into
anything else that's kind of a it's an
incredibly easy walk through the park of
going oh I lost tempers
my money today sure it's real estate
it's not gonna just disappear it's like
a physical item so I think I've taken an
incredibly risky maneuver I'm younger so
I'm in my early 30s so I can take this
sort of risk I don't have a wife or kids
I don't have a mortgage so for me I very
much dawn where it's gone I do not
recommend that for others I think a
healthy percentage of your portfolio
would be to take a look at what other
assets you hold if Bitcoin were to 10x
you know would that be something
meaningful to you you know so I think a
1% allocation is sort of a really easy
decision I think 1% if you lose 1% sure
you can tweet at me and be like hey Dan
I lost 1% I'm super mad but I think
losing 1% most people can stomach that
risk but if that 10x is now that's 10%
of your portfolio which is super
meaningful and Bitcoin as you've
properly mentioned on on this podcast
before is uncorrelated it's an asset
that when you add it to your portfolio
improves your Sharpe ratio so it
improves your return per unit of risk so
Bitcoin as an asset is I think a
necessity for any portfolio as to what
percentage I think a lower one for most
people due to how Bhalla tile it is I
mean let's put it this way I've lost a
lot of sleep and I'm surprised I don't
have like a beard full of gray hair by
now I think there's a lot of folks who
came in in 2017 and 18 and they got a
taste of the true volatility right
because when you have exposure to
Bitcoin and you see you know 5 or 10%
movements that's ok and then you even
see things like you know an 85% drawdown
but that happens over an entire year ok
that you know obviously sucks but like
it's a little bit each day and so
there's not one moment where you're like
holy [ __ ] and then the really big
volatile moment that happened since 2000
17 or 18 it was actually a 40% increase
in one day I think there's you know kind
of mid last year and so that you know
generally most people had seen some
volatility relative on the Bitcoin side
but not
true volatility until in March when
there was a 50% drawdown in a single day
and I you know literally there are
people like hey man like is it going to
zero rate I mean let's put it this way
it didn't feel good I'm not sitting
there with 90 person 90 plus percent of
my net worth of Bitcoin looking at it 80
3,800 in feeling a very joyful that day
it was a it was tough I mean it does
become easier but you really have to be
convicted in the trade you have to
really believe in the trade and that's
where I think the word hobble actually
means something a bit more than just
Bitcoin
I think hollow represents being
committed to an idea whether that be a
relationship or an investment it's
looking at it objectively and going what
do I find out of this what do I really
believe in what are the traits about
this opportunity do I find that I want
to hold and so Hottel I think represents
conviction it represents in this world
of being a belief being able to easily
switch between different options it
shows it shows belief and conviction and
something and so you know to hobbles
Bitcoin requires an immense amount of
belief what's funny is a lot of people a
lot of people got in late 17 and they so
they survived to the bear market and you
earned your badge develop your badge of
honor you've you've survived the the
bear market and you know it's kind of
funny as you earn these stripes you go
through these moments where you
encounter this like intense emotional
struggle but we're about to incur
another one bull markets similarly a lot
of people don't think about it but bull
markets can have their own set of
emotional issues for example what
happens when all corn pumps and you're
holding Bitcoin and you're tempted
because that altcoin does 3 next you're
tempted to go put your money into that
you hear the sirens call come come join
this new narrative this new narrative
around a osore whatever it's a it's a
shiny new thing and so you're tempted to
take your bitcoins and put them into
something else and that's its own unique
challenge different even so that I would
say like the bear market it's a
distinctly different challenge to
Holland also I think that hotle is that
rallying cry for a bit corner and
a lot of you guys survived your 17:17
through now but now it's time to survive
a bull run and that's a little bit
different yeah and the other piece of
the bull runs that people forget is you
know I think it was in 2017 all of the
gains pretty much came in nine separate
days rights if you take off those nine
biggest gain days you pretty much would
have been flat if not lost money in
seventeen and then I like to remind
people like there's plenty of people who
lost money in 2017 in Bitcoin right
they're just trading around being in you
know basically stupid and rather than
just holding the asset trying to time
the market and as we know humans are
really good selling when the price goes
down and by now I ran up right not a lot
of people are in incredible traders
where they've got their plugged into
different data feeds they're able to
fight that FOMO and fear you know really
to be a good trader you have to fight
the opposite feeling of what you have so
if you're feeling greedy then you sell
if you're feeling bullish than you
already feel embarrassed and goodbye and
so that a lot of people have that I
think huddle is a great investment
strategy as well like these these market
swings will be incredibly intense and
unless you've got some sort of exit
price or exit time in mind then you're
going to be shaken out through these
intense cycles it yeah you're right in
2017 you've got a very few days that
were actually you know represented a
large portion of the gains and if you're
day trading like you can't predict when
that date will be so your best option is
just a huddle it's also a little bit
more peaceful you just thoughtful and
and see what happens versus a waking up
at 2 a.m. and checking your the price of
Bitcoin on your phone which we've all
done I still do it once in a while when
there's an incredible bull run or
there's a dip and when you dip down the
3,800 I gotta admit I woke up a few
times in the middle of the night to
check and you picked the price and see
what was going on I wasn't worried it
was gonna go to zero but it's always
president it's always there yeah
and that leads me to one of my favorite
questions to ask people is just like
what would change your mind right so
obviously I think you and I both don't
have very strong conviction in Bitcoin
in the protocol and kind of the impact
it can have on the world
but what are the things that could
happen that would actually change your
mind even to the point of you just
throwing your hands up and saying look
it's over right bitcoins not going to
be what I thought it was and I'm gonna
be something else yeah I got I got some
flack from this on Twitter but I'll
bring it up here
it's about Bitcoin going below a certain
price threshold bitcoins price is
incredibly important bitcoins price
represents the aggregate shared belief
in Bitcoin so the biggest worry that I
would have is that FUD eventually
permeates a Bitcoin modelers mind so
intensely that it would destroy their
conviction I mean that's the only way to
really kill Bitcoin is you have to kill
the belief of Bitcoin every one of our
minds and you know when Bitcoin had
3,800 that was still above crush depth
but with Bitcoin as Bitcoin survives
over the years that's you know as
Bitcoin survives it builds more and more
belief aka The Linde effect but Bitcoin
hasn't gone below the last previous high
right so in the 2017 Bolt run the
drawdown didn't go below 1200 which was
2013 speak and so we establish these
higher lows if we see Bitcoin break that
it sort of breaks The Linde effect where
you know let's say 3,800 let's say we
went down to a thousand that destroys
Linde because now in all of our minds
Bitcoin could go lower than that last
previous high there is no higher low and
that sort of reverse is Linde and so I
call that like crush depth and luckily
we didn't go there and I mentioned on
Twitter I was like look I think there's
a material issue if Bitcoin goes below
like 3000 that was the low for the 17
bubble like 17 don't draw down through
2020 3000 was below if we go below that
we're resetting Linde Bitcoin won't die
but it may take a few more decades than
what we what we had hoped and that to me
is is such a setback that I think could
be hugely negative for the space so
because if Bitcoin goes below that value
it means the aggregate shared belief of
Bitcoin has evaporated so it's not the
price represents that shared belief and
so people don't realize that people go
oh the price doesn't matter but no the
price does matter it represents all of
us and if no one puts in a bid and the
price keeps dropping and you know it was
but none of us put in a bid it means no
one none of us believe in it which aka
means Bitcoin has died so I do think
that's a scary moment when you know if
we saw Lindy affect get reversed if we
saw Bitcoin fall below that high or low
that to me would be a very routine sign
yeah and it's really interesting you
think of it as like the price is a a
signal for belief or I don't think of a
hurting when really talked about that
before but it's a pretty pretty good
point
yeah I wrote a article called the
information theory of money so a lot of
people have heard about this through the
efficient market hypothesis that the
price of an equity represents all of the
information out there about it and so we
can kind of think about it like a
one-way hash function where the price
represents a one-way hash function of
all the aggregate bullish and bearish
sentiment over the price if society if
all the individuals participating in the
market it felt differently the price
would be something different you know
there no-one would have been a bit or no
one would have sold the price is that
one way hash function that that the
compression of all the information in
the world and represented in that one
value and I think that's really cool
because it it essentially shows us what
people believe in Bitcoin
what's the aggregate should believe
what's the the whole world what do we
think about it compressed into one and
that's where a lot of people will go oh
is is to having priced in and I'm like
well was it priced in in 2012 or 2016
it's priced in for those who care and
there's not many people who care about
Bitcoin it we're talking tens of
millions not even hundreds of millions
but there's billions of people out there
and so Vic wins priced in for those who
already believe and care about it and
it's not priced in for the 99.9% we
haven't done then why would he take it
even a step further right so it's
definite priced in for the people who
don't care about it and I would even
argue back that I don't think it's
priced in for everyone who cares about
it because there's a lot of people who
hold Bitcoin who actually don't
understand the having right they don't
realize how it works they couldn't tell
you how it works
and they don't have an idea that of what
the impact is and even I'd go as far as
to say there's definitely people who
hold Bitcoin right now who don't even
know the happenings coming now I don't
think it's a big percentage right but
there's some percentage of people who
bought it you know a year ago two years
ago three years ago there's not paying
attention to it it's a long-term
investment for them maybe they check the
price every once in a while but they
don't even know the happening is coming
and so when you look at it that way for
it to be priced in you would have to
have a hundred percent of people
actually understand that this is
happening understand what that means and
then have consensus around what's gonna
happen afterwards and I just always tell
people like I don't think that you can
say that with a straight face the guy I
just don't believe that right I think
that's a great point you know I you and
I both get into weeds a lot and I think
we forget to zoom out and look at the
average Bitcoin participant who may not
really look at any sort of technical
analysis or look at any research reports
they might have just bought Bitcoin cuz
their friend told them to buy Bitcoin
and they have a coin base account that's
probably a very large portion of all
bitcoiners so yeah I totally agree so
one of the things that is top of mine
now for a lot of people as they watch
the Federal Reserve print trillions of
dollars and other central banks around
the world is this idea of a return to
sound money and the Fiat experiment
coming to an end right maybe it happens
maybe it doesn't but one of those paths
is Bitcoin as a global reserve currency
another path could be return to the gold
standard maybe talk a little bit about
just like one do you think that's
feasible into if we did go back to a
gold standard what would the impact on
Bitcoin actually end up being yeah so
that's a really fun game theory which is
as governments across the world start to
lose the faith of their citizens the
trust of their citizens as they abused
their money will they go so a lot of you
know people forget that Russia China and
the US government all have gold reserves
and many others do as well Germany UK so
what happens if they return to the gold
standard what happens if they attempt to
return to a period of being fiscally
responsible well I think we've kind
with corona before corona I think that
could have been like a legitimate
argument but post corona was the amount
of money printing that has gone on I
don't really see a lot of politicians
wanting to peg themselves to gold which
would really limit their ability to
spend aka provide benefits their
constituents or perceived benefits to
their constituents I mean when money
printing occurs we all pay for it
there's no such thing as a free lunch
it's it's a good I think I think we
could see central banks and governments
do that if Bitcoin becomes a larger
threat so as Bitcoin grows an adoption
aka price it becomes a larger and larger
threat let's say Bitcoin hits in a
trillion 10 trillion market cap nowadays
legitimately a goal 2.0 a recognized
globally as a goal 2.0 we could see
banks we could see these governments and
central banks to do that
going back to a gold standard however a
lot of these aren't audited we have an
audited Fort Knox in a very long time it
would severely constrain spending and
also once you've lost that faith and
belief by your by your core constituency
they're not going to instantly believe
you when you show them a bunch of shiny
old rocks they might only be convinced
if you show them digital gold something
that is completely verifiable with with
gold we still have to have trust and
that's where you know Satoshi when you
first wrote about Bitcoin said you know
central banks and banks they all require
trust to work and that's the core
problem so at the underlying you know
belief in this gold the belief in the
central bank's the belief in the
government all resides and Trust and yes
they could go back to the gold standard
but they will probably have lost the
trust of their citizens long before then
so it won't really make too much of a
difference yeah and it feels like I
think he talked about this on Peter
McCormick's podcast about this idea of
like greed being built into the protocol
and you know when you talk about Satoshi
and some of the design you know kind of
Bitcoin is beautiful right the design of
Bitcoin actually works maybe talk
a little bit and elaborate on that greed
built into the protocol what you mean by
that yeah so everyone remembers Gordon
Gekko from Wall Street where he says
greed is good
what Satoshi I think thought it was that
greed is inevitable human beings have
the innate nature to accumulate
resources aka make more money speculate
to increase their amount of resources
that they have in the hopes that the
speculation the speculative asset that
the purchase goes up in value then I can
sell that and buy more things so Satoshi
early on before Bitcoin was worth
anything
he built a viral loop into the product
and the one variable that he plugged in
is that he assumed humans would be
greedy that they would speculate with
Bitcoin
so Satoshi says yeah I'm somewhat
paraphrasing here but he goes as the
coins value Rises people become more
aware of it and as they become aware of
it they start to buy into that
increasing speculative value and so that
crease it makes the price go higher so
he's essentially describing a FOMO viral
loop that as the price increases that
that's singularly alone will bring in
new people and that's incredible and a
lot of people understands the depth to
was Satoshi thought about how Bitcoin
might succeed again Bitcoin that was not
worth anything when he wrote this which
is incredible right so he he knew that
he understood human nature really well
and I think that was something that a
lot of people don't give him credit for
they go oh Satoshi coded up Bitcoin kind
of but his way his marketing approach
like how he marketed Bitcoin to
cypherpunks with the white paper was
really smart he used a lot of verbage
that they understood the way he
understood human nature when it comes to
being greedy and speculating was was
really really interesting and then when
we look at how Bitcoin protects itself
how proof-of-work works then we see some
really really interesting
characteristics so a lot of people worry
that through the having's the having's
reduce the amount of newly minted coins
that's called the block subsidy the
block subsidy is a component of the
block reward block reward is
subsidy plus transaction fees now what
miners do is miners expand a hepatic
capex which is the Asics those
specialized mining equipment and they
spend ongoing effects on electricity
bite from for doing that or are proving
that they did that proof of work bhiku
Bitcoin miners are compensated with the
block reward now some people worry that
as the subsidy decreases in that block
reward over time that miners won't be
compensated properly but what's
interesting is that as the block subsidy
has decreased we've seen the u.s. dollar
value of the block reward increased
exponentially and that's due to
speculative bubbles and as those
speculative bubbles occur we see a
corresponding rise in transaction fees
so Satoshi understood in Satoshi talks
about this and he he says it's someone
in the comical manner at least that's
how I'm interpreting it he goes they
will either be a lot of transaction fees
in ten years or none he's like it's
either gonna catch on or not
but Bitcoin inherently a Bitcoin has
been constructed to understand human
nature to where if bitcoins value Rises
the block subsidy block reward will
become greater which will financially
incentivize the miners to behave
properly which will then protect the
network which is now protecting more and
more money so as Bitcoin grows and
adoption the security grows as well it's
not a linear one to one but it still
grows and so that is really cool and I
don't think a lot of people really
appreciate that that Bitcoin security
model grows with the growth of the
network for sure um leads to the
question who do you think Satoshi is
that's a that's a great question I think
you know if you had to pick to be how
Finney or Nick Szabo I mean those are
those were like four to classic ones I
think Finney exhibits a lot of great
characteristics I did a tweet storm on
half and a few weeks ago I'm I've signed
up for cryonics so I am getting cryo
preserved when I die just like how
Finney did but I wasn't influenced by
health and you I've been into this for
the last decade go ahead
why do you think that it could be one of
those two so what was really interesting
about how is that how ghostwrote PGP he
understood that to be the face of
something was to also take the flack for
it so Phil Zimmerman he was kind of a
face for PGP he I think I think he had a
legal battle with the US government for
like ten years
and so how goes for a PGP for largely
known as goes he's been largely known to
have ghostwritten PGP forever Phil
Zimmerman and so that's a very unique
sort of perspective to have as a
cypherpunk to actually put out their
production level code that is
scrutinized by US government's is huge
you've got health and he also came up
with reusable proof-of-work a very core
underpinning on how Bitcoin works he is
one of the first people to be positive
about Bitcoin Halfin II predicts Bitcoin
could hit ten million dollars a Bitcoin
in the first couple months when bitcoins
out I mean that's unbelievable ish but
that's that's crazy bullish and Bitcoin
wasn't even worth a penny and how
fitting is it going like oh it could be
worth ten million dollars a Bitcoin
someday he also was the first recipient
of a Bitcoin transaction of one of the
first miners if we look at like health
in his language and his writing style
he's very very much like Satoshi very
patient very calm
there has been some analysis done I was
writing a somewhat correlated so I think
you know how to clicks you know checks a
lot of those boxes there's also
deficiencies though and that's where I
don't think it's clear-cut that Hal or
Nick you know that they are Satoshi
there's there's gaps that don't make
sense so is it one person is it many I
tend to believe it's probably one or two
I don't really seen it be more than a
few I think I think to keep a secret
like that and to keep that amount of
wealth that Satoshi you mind early on to
keep that you know to that touch that
takes so much self-control and so much
maturity I I don't know of a human in my
network that would have that sort of
self-restraint so this individual I
think at this individual or a very small
group I think
it was probably one of those guys at
least you know Satoshi himself says that
a lot of the work was influenced by how
Nick solloway died
Adam back I think it's one of those two
they seem to be the closest fit we're
probably never gonna know a good
question that was posed to me was as
time progresses do you think will become
more or less likely to find Stowe she I
think would become less likely you know
data decays over time so she gets older
people start to forget I think it's a
little tough to kind of pin down those
details as those details coming up
evaporate it almost feels like there's a
a bell curve right in the beginning
nobody cares about Bitcoin so who the
Creator is doesn't matter then you get
into a highly speculative phase probably
actually around 17 and 18 when literally
like media companies we're trying to
figure it out they really want to know
and then you get on the other side of
the bell curve and bitcoin is Bitcoin
and people don't care about the creation
story as much anymore because it's just
this thing that they use right and as
time goes on cut the history doesn't
matter totally I mean I don't think most
people can could tell you who built the
Internet absolutely it's a good look at
it what are your thoughts on on various
other aspects of of crypto so things
like defy other blockchains anything
that you're interested in and
understanding that you know you're
probably very similar to me if like
bitcoin is the king and there's really
kind of the main focus of a lot of this
but is there anything else that you're
kind of looking at saying hey that's
interesting yeah so I believe that big
that blockchain was special
purpose-built to build Bitcoin I wrote
an article that was a comprehensive
analysis of Bitcoin security model as
people remember earlier in this
conversation I talked about how miners
are rewarded with that block reward when
you look at how this is all constructed
blockchain technology is very bad at
doing almost everything like it's not
this general-purpose stuff is one tool
for all things it's block chains
sacrifice and have trade-offs
in those sacrifices and trade-offs are
really bad I mean it'd be you basically
sacrifice everything to have a sound
money had to have a goal 2.0 and so
mm-hmm
you know we could look at it from that
perspective which is that a blockchain
inherently can do many things due to how
it's built
due to the intricate maker nature of how
it all works also we can look at the
empirical data we can look at the 10,000
dead crypto currencies and NGO or crypto
projects and go okay well it seems like
all of these failed and their hypothesis
was that there are other use cases for
blockchain tech I think most blockchain
and tech out there now is basically
trying to mimic the wealth effect of
Bitcoin by producing a narrative that
resonates etherium is a good example
atheria Marta Daz ADAP platform and they
came out with that because that
resonates very well with tech people I
live in San Francisco I've been here for
80 years
tech people hear the word DAP and they
go oh an app an app apps an app you know
platforms app stores and apps
oh this is the new Apple but for
decentralized you know D central de
centralized nature and so Silicon Valley
wholeheartedly embraced etherion because
you fundamentally don't understand sound
money or gold or the economic system at
all they understand apps but as we saw
that was a I would consider a gross
grossly misinterpreted or grossly
marketed narrative because there's no
way you can scale an application on
ethereum right like as soon as we sell
crypto please get any sort of meaningful
attraction which meaningful attraction
means 10,000 users I've built a couple
side-project apps that have 10,000 users
those were something I work on on the
weekend like this negligible not even
anything material right I've worked at
uber I was on writer growth which was
that writer app as the app that you all
call uber I was working on that team
with Andrew Chen like we're looking at
metrics that are 10 to a hundred million
right and so you know this this DAT
platform a narrative was basically fake
and so that dissipated fundraising
platform narrative in 2017 for aetherium
that also dissipated and now etherium
the etherium community is pivoting to
sound money [ __ ] kidding me like what
this is not it's I mean I remember going
to Satoshi roundtable on 2015 the first
one and they're all talking about a
theory and being this DAP platform and
now they're talking about it being a
sound money is crazy right so we're
seeing in one of the oldest alternative
use cases for blockchain tech we're
seeing their narrative pivot to sound
money so I think overall like the only
surviving narrative here is probably
gonna be a sound money or money
narrative as we see that blockchain tech
now of course this is my personal
opinion doesn't represent my employers
but yeah just just personally how I
think about it for sure and I guess as
part of it right you know and I've I've
been very non shy about my thoughts on a
lot of this and it just feels like one
there's a lot of people holding on to
the narrative of what I'm built or what
I'm working on or what I hold is quote
unquote working but the metrics to your
point are and the grand scheme of things
negligible at best right I mean just
just the numbers that we're talking
about here just honestly don't matter
and I think part of that is there's a
balance between like you want to
encourage the experimentation and the
innovation and and the work right
because it's good to have some more
people working on things that are
tangentially related and you know come
in the same industry at the same time
there's this element of like should you
be working on the next project or should
you actually be taking your skills and
time and resources and devoting them to
the most important project right and I
think that balance is is hard for a lot
of people to kind of think through
humans respond to incentives and the
incentive to print money is irresistible
so when humans get were given the
ability to print money by creating a
token that represented some sort of
utilization or some sort of narrative
they did it and that's an irresistible
function of humans I don't think that it
is
about a good thing it just was
inevitable working on Bitcoin there is
no Bitcoin no core there isn't like a
core entity that can give you a grant
there's nothing baked into the protocol
like C cash that gives you no X payouts
for developers and so working on Bitcoin
is somewhat of a selfless act it's hard
to monetize that and so other people
felt that monetization through money
printing was probably the easier way to
go you know you're a growth guy I'm a
growth guy I think you worked at
snapchat right and Facebook and snapchat
snapchat yeah so no I find a very large
lack of product and growth people in the
space you see a ton of engineers who you
know they're the projects that they like
to tinker on were never taken seriously
they never knew how to monetize it they
never knew how to like build a product
around it and so they went to market
with her ICO they went to market with a
shiny tech idea but as we know to find
product market fit you can't start with
a shiny tech idea you have to iterate
and find traction
that's a solve a problem for someone and
there are metrics to indicate if it's
tracking closer or farther away from
product market fit one might be a
flattening of the retention curve to
where users are sticking around and
they're not leaving a platform anymore
other than leaking the product anymore
or the protocol and so we've just seen a
complete lack of product metrics and
people came in and they bought these
narratives because they were hoping he
was going to pump and there was very few
product minded people going wait so what
KPIs are you guys monitoring the monitor
success they were like I don't know a
trading volume and so you know I think
there's been a complete lack of product
mindset in this space because money is
easy you can print money and make
millions tens of millions and even
billions for some people doing that for
sure you're a Kraken now talk to us a
little bit about kind of cracking as a
as a business in a platform and then
kind of what you're doing there on a day
to day basis yeah so Kraken was founded
by Jesse Powell he's an incredible
individual in the space he was also part
of those early
in San Francisco that's where I met him
for the first time back in early 13
Jessi put tens of thousands of his own
Bitcoin into cracking I don't think
there's many founders like that and I
think that's a story that not many
people know that I feel is important to
reflect how much of a skin in the game I
found her has in their own company you
know when you look at other crypto
startups or other startups in Silicon
Valley that's a very rare thing to see
as a founder put their own a lot of
their own capital into the company so I
have a lot of respect for Jessi putting
his own money and and I know it wasn't
easy I think you know there were some
struggles in the 15/16 bear market too
where things didn't look so good and so
cracking I think is demonstrated
incredible resiliency it's one of the
oldest Bitcoin company a crypto
companies out there Jessi's are a
founder you know I think a lot of what
we'd like though I think we could be a
little bit better on user experience and
I think that's something that we're
cognizant does and I think that's
something that we're going to be working
on in 2020 it's very top of mind I know
Jessi is really empathetic towards the
avid experience of both the retail
trader and the larger traders and qej
funds and other institutional types so
that's what we're really laser focused
on is making that user experience better
being having more liquid markets kind of
going back to the basics a little bit
but I think these are very very core
functions of what we do and you know a
lot of companies out there are going and
building I mean kind of more other
friends do experimental stuff but I
think we just want to provide that core
service that we do really really well
yeah it makes sense that and then maybe
just talk a little bit about when people
go in the center for crack and like what
exactly can they do on the platform
because there's obviously the exchange
component but what else yeah so Kraken
is a spot trading a spot exchange which
means you can buy Bitcoin you can buy
and sell Bitcoin you can buy and sell
other crypto assets we do enable margin
trading as well so you can trade with
leverage I would recommend you only do
that if you're sophisticated trader we
also have a futures platform called
crypto facilities that's only for
institutional types and that's in Europe
as well we have crypto watch
a crypto watch is a multi venue trading
platform you can also go there to check
how Bitcoin another crypto assets
movement price it's a really beautiful
website really well-designed and kind of
like you might be a good replacement for
coin market cap you know with crackin I
mean our core function is buying and
selling Bitcoin if you look at our fee
structure or the cheapest in the space
and if you look at bit wisest we bitwise
as real volume index for one of the most
liquid real volume exchanges out there
this is also validated by keiko and by
whale pool so when you see a price at
crack and when you see volume at
cracking when you see the depth of the
order book that's real volume and a lot
of the crypto space you're going to see
exchanges with fake volume they're going
to manipulate the numbers are gonna add
zeros to it they're gonna have different
you know they're gonna have bit in ass
quarters where as soon as you trade
against it they evaporate Kraken through
through independent third parties very
much the shows that Kraken has true
volume it has it's a it's a very pure
exchange in terms of which the the
execution that you can which you see in
the order book is real and I think if I
remember correctly just they told me
that like most of the company is remote
right and kind of very decentralized in
nature yeah so Kraken
so Kraken very much embodies a lot of
the og crypto culture which I think it
kind of be evidenced by the recent high
earnings of a couple different
individuals over at Kraken
but yeah the the remote first culture is
kind of a core component of that
decentralized og crypto nature you know
to not have one centralized place where
someone could come in and and cause
damage to Kraken Kraken is very much
distributed first so I work in San
Francisco I work in the San Francisco
office but very few people actually go
to the office it's most people work from
home everyone is remote first and you're
then is a few officers across the world
you can then go work in those offices if
you like but naturally everyone is
remote for remote first got it makes it
makes sense before we wrap up I'd asked
everyone for some questions on Twitter
and my favorite one came from Catherine
Cole who said what was the biggest
obstacle in your life and how did you
get through it yeah that's that's a
really good question I I think it was
probably my transition to tech I was an
analyst at a small investment firm in
Dallas that's where I'm from originally
and that was my first job out of college
they relocated me to San Francisco and
early 13 and so when I build zero block
I was actually building that while I was
working full-time as an analyst at at
the small investment firm I didn't know
anyone in San Francisco but I moved out
here I'm so sorry I knew my roommate he
was the only person I knew when I moved
out to San Francisco I didn't have any
buddies from Stanford or Berkeley I
didn't know anything about girls culture
growth mindset of product mindset I knew
nothing about how what the whole product
even meant you know I really didn't know
under understand anything about tech I
had no idea how startups were fun I
created how you iterate and find product
market fit and so my greatest struggle
was my stumbling and bumbling into tech
that's the way I put it because honestly
a lot of it was luck a lot of it was
pure obsession to go build something
great was a roadblock for example and I
think a lot of people might find this
little bit humorous so back in 2013 you
might remember this but on mobile Apple
recommended apps be designed that were
to be designed as hue morphic so
skeuomorphic meant that buttons look
like buttons now when you look at an app
it's all flat and that's called flat UI
it's the kind of very slick futuristic
looking most most apps have that design
aesthetic so when I design zero block
because I was everything other than the
code I designed it with flat UI because
I didn't know how to make bevels and
stuff in Photoshop so I I literally you
know I obsessed over making it really
simple because I could design anything
more complex so the black and white the
black and white aesthetic was because I
didn't want to have a color palette that
was is more difficult to work with
people loved it because it was
simple and that kind of built my
foundational knowledge about how to
build great products is delivering value
to the user right away
demonstrates why they want to use the
product so I you know I didn't put an
onboarding flow in because that would be
more work you know I launched them right
into the product and simply showed them
what they cared about and so that that
kind of you know through that stumbling
and bumbling process I learned in tech
mmm the core fundamental components of
building great products how teams work
with each other how to work and build
and iterate and go launch and be
successful also how to fail with with
change tip we failed we didn't find
product market fit so you know with a
lot of that as well I had experience in
early crypto startups that doesn't get
you a job in Silicon Valley it didn't
really mean much at all so when I got a
job in uber that was a very like lucky
stroke to where I was very specifically
knew I specifically understood a very
intimate thing around app stores and
that's what who were hired before and
that kind of like opened up my
experience it's usually a bigger tech
company to understand how they operate
how they think and grow product from 10
million monthly active users to a
hundred million so I would say the
biggest challenge in my life was was
getting into tacking and something that
I'm personally really passionate about
I've helped two buddies get into tech
Lucca which is a big tax company in the
space Jake Benson and I played high
school football together and he slept on
my couch three months when he started
lieutenant San Francisco so you know
once I kind of moved up the ladder a
little bit and understood tech I helped
a bunch of buddies from Texas get out
here and also I invested in like a buddy
startup called career karma and they
help people learn how to code so for me
it's kind of a it's kind of a you once
you get there you gotta help others come
along the way so it's it's a big passion
for me for sure I recently had Ruben
Harris from career karma on the alcohol
for a while what um what's the most
important book you've ever read
[Music]
that's a that's a good question I mean
that's hard it's kinda like asking what
your favorite flavor of ice cream is or
like what your favorite food is it kind
of depends on the mood a little bit man
is you know the Bitcoin standard is
pretty phenomenal it has a good corner
of course that's like a go-to let's see
you know some of my earlier books that I
read that I think really kind of changed
my perspective we're like around Malcolm
Gladwell that was really cool I think
Malcolm Gladwell was it could have been
able to me to zoom out a little bit and
kind of think a little bit more about
behavioral things and how humans respond
to different sort of sets of incentives
and and you know how to look at data and
this this was when I was you know pretty
young so I think that was kind of
formulated in terms of helping me better
kind of zoom out and zoom out from like
what you learn in school context and
zoom Adam can understand that won't
behavioral side of things so I think
that that's probably one of my favorite
earlier books that I read for sure I got
one more question for you then he had
asked me one to finish up we gotta talk
about aliens believer non-believer
well certainly given the vastness of
space we would likely see a lot of alien
life I find that somewhat probabilistic
how much intelligent life is there I
think we might find a lot of goo out
there we might find a lot of like moss
and fungi and very primitive life-forms
something that does worry me is that
when we look into space if you were to
build like a Death Star or a Star
Destroyer all those big spaceships in
star wars if those were moving around
space we would see huge energy
displacements these things are gigantic
but we don't see that anywhere we don't
see any abnormal energy displacement
across the whole universe which would be
kind of scary if we are the only
advanced species out there so
intuitively I would say we should see a
lot of life is it intelligent maybe
maybe not I am a little bit it's a
little sad to see that we don't see a
lot of energy displacement from like
giant civilizations way out there which
I don't know if that's a good or bad
thing
but I kind of refused
that aliens are this like evil malicious
sort of species I think if they achieve
that level of consciousness and they can
build spaceships that travel across the
universe they're probably not gonna come
check us out and destroy us I think
that's kind of a very human sort of
thing to feel which is oh what if this
new weird thing comes and comes and
hurts me you know I think with any new
technology or any new thing we were
scared of it naturally so I think if we
did encounter aliens would likely be a
yeah would likely be a good thing yeah
it's so weird thing you're not a you
know you're not freaked out by in the
UFO videos that recently got released
man I don't know about that mean those
are pretty wild I watch a few of those
and you know I also don't think that if
I'm gonna if I'm an alien species and I
fly a billion years or some [ __ ]
not going to come around and mess around
of maybe maybe fighter pilots right it's
like if I'm gonna show up I'm gonna show
up in a pretty grandiose style I'm gonna
roll up and be like hello you know I I
think kind of plane a plane tag with
fighter jets it's a little bit of our
imagination kind of running wild as to
what an alien species might do like
let's put it this way if I'm an alien I
travel that long I want to have some
meaningful conversations I don't want to
play tag with fighters so I think those
are likely to be anomalies like fight
like maybe some light anomalies or
tracking anomalies but you know I don't
know how that equipment is manufactured
so like I really can't uh I don't know
how real it is about yeah I have no clue
but but just the fact that they're
releasing it is is pretty interesting
what one question do you have for me to
add officious thing well what are you
most excited about in terms of
technology with Bitcoin
like it can be a product or service
built on top of Bitcoin or it can be an
improvement to the core protocol so I'm
gonna cheat I'm not gonna give you a
technology answer I'm gonna give you a
boring but uh but I think powerful
perspective which is time I think that's
the most important thing and it's the
thing that Bitcoin has on its side right
if you think of most technology they get
built on and there's a timeline to it so
especially when you raise money right in
a venture capital private equity style I
like I think it's Andrew Wilkinson from
tiny always says like it's like raising
money and then getting a gun put to your
head and basically do X before you know
the gun gets pulled right and so I think
that there's these artificial time lines
that get put on a lot of technology
advancements and companies and things
like that but at the same time this
isn't just a technology play right kind
of this idea that money is a belief
system and it takes time to build trust
it takes time to build that belief it
takes time to educate people and get
that buy-in and so I always look it's
just like what's the most important
thing for Bitcoin it is the expiration
of time which sucks as an answer because
people want instant gratification and
they want to know how they can kind of
you know accelerate this and do all this
stuff but the time kind of interlaces
with that as well because it takes time
for developers to products it takes time
for liquidity to build up it takes time
for people to get educated and so it's
kind of this weird overlap but
everything to me just roll revolves
around time and the nice thing is you
know so far so good we're what 11 years
in or so and and I think people actually
blown away by how much Bitcoin has has
accomplished in that time period and so
when you look out kind of another 11
years it's like well you know what could
it do in that time period like think
we're all gonna be pretty surprised
right and so I always fall back to the
Bill Gates quote we overestimate you
know in one year what we can do but we
underestimate what can be done in 10 and
so I think that's the you know bitcoin
is kind of the epitome of that and so
we'll see kind of what happens there
yeah I totally agree awesome man where
um where can we send people if they
listen to this they want to get in touch
with you with crack in it would be the
best place to send them yeah so for me
if you're you know if you want kind of
more shorter cookie or takes on a Bick
the environment inhaled twitter.com
slash day and held if you like more
long-form content you like to spend some
time we're getting a long article you go
to Dan he'll calm and check out my blog
for crackin I take go to cracking calm a
lot of people listening this or probably
get more interested in the spot exchange
and where you can buy and sell Bitcoin
go to cracking calm you can get signed
up there if you're interested in crypto
watch I think crypto watches a really
phenomenal way for you to go check
bitcoin and check the price of bitcoin
the other cryptids that's crypto watch
and so just give that a quick google and
you can go find that but yeah there's
the two products that recommend a
cracking and palm thanks for having me
on really had a really had a great
conversation with you and i'll see you
around
let me be doing this for for a long time
and your enthusiasm has not dissipated
which i think is important so keep it up
and we'll go have this again sounds good
Cheers